Tyson Fury has called on the government
to act on knife crime after his cousin
was stabbed to death in Altrincham last
night in an Instagram post paying
tribute to Rico Burton the heavyweight
boxing champion said tougher sentencing
is needed
at least 11 stabbings have been reported
across England this week alone
the Ben kinsella trust and educational
charity set up following the murder of
Ben kinseller in 2008 says there's been
a 10 increase in knife crime in England
and Wales in the 12 months to March 2022
the trust also reported a 46 increase in
knife crime in England and Wales
compared to March 2012.
joining me now is Dr Mark Prince Obi who
set up a foundation in the name of his
son Kian who was stabbed to death when
he was 15 welcome to you thanks very
much for speaking to us this this
morning this evening I should say I mean
it's 16 years since uh Keim was killed
um seems like a long time but I'm sure
it's no time to you at all do you think
anything has changed in that time
um I don't even think it's about what I
think it's about what's evident
evident that nothing has changed it's
evident that a Situation's gone worse
it's evident that everything that I've
discussed and talked about whether it be
on the news whether it be with Sadiq
whoever it be with whoever's in charge
government doesn't matter it falls on
deaf ears and our young people's lives
aren't valued Enough by the people that
we put in power to be able to make the
necessary changes and be able to put
things in place to help educate to help
be aware to help support families and
parents who are going through very
difficult times with their young people
and basically to put a wrap around
program to help hurting people who end
up hurting people
why is it still happening
to do anything is they're ignoring it
leadership
it's all about leadership so if you go
into the communities who's in leadership
families parents the ones in charge so
we need to take stock of how much our
young people are listening and being
respectful in the home because it starts
from in the home leadership is with our
country they need to ensure that things
are in place to make sure that there are
um consequences for carrying a knife and
the work that I'm doing I find out so
many times that young people find that
there's no consequences for carrying a
knife they're back out on the streets
again so why why would there be any
change if there's no one know any if
there's no change from the top coming
right down
sorry just to interrupt there are
consequences for for carrying a knife to
be found are you saying that there
should be tougher sentences no the
sentences that are there need to be
applied I'm saying to you that they're
not being applied I'm saying to you that
that young people are getting a slap on
the wrist and being sent back out I'm
saying to you that so many cases that I
personally know of and the ones I don't
know about but people talk to me about
when nothing's been done but the kids
been found the young people have been
found with knives coming into school
nothing's been done young people's been
caught with knives on the street
nothing's been done they're back out
again
that may be partner order they may be
put on the youth within the team
whatever it is but there's no
consequences so they're carrying knives
still even when they're doing their
youth offended team or their community
service what impact do you think it will
have Tyson Fury speaking out
it will have a big impact because you've
got a big platform and that's the sad
thing about this world
so I'm going to ask Tyson Fury to you're
serious about this because what happens
is sometimes the sad thing is until it
happens to people in their families
that's when it really really hits home
about the pain of this and it shouldn't
have to every young person out there
could be my young person so when I talk
to these youths at school I'm talking to
them like they're my sons they're my
daughters I'm sharing with them the
things that are going to empower their
life so they don't waste their lives
taking this journey that's what I do
that's why I'm giving my life for so I'm
markson Tyson Fury let's do this we've
got the same background we come from
boxing we're both Champions let's do
this make a big impact make some changes
and really speak to the young people out
there on the next level because you've
got that pulling power as well and we
know how to use that bro so let's do
this because the government ain't listen
I've been doing this for 16 years and
I've had to put in some some big events
now so we could try and get a premises
try and get resources so we could
demonstrate to the government and
National models needed and we're going
to Pilot this if you guys ain't gonna do
it we just need the corporates and the
backing to be able to do it you can see
the passion in me because I'm tired of
hearing these stories I'm tired of being
called on news so discuss about another
young person's life when we could do a
lot more about this and change this
narrative